(synthesizer)
- [Narrator] Milk,
it's the elixir all mammals
feed to their young.
Deep inside the National
Zoo in Washington, D.C.,
a team of scientists are devoted
to unlocking the wonders of the white gold
to help animals like baby Fiona,
but more on that later.
Welcome to the world's largest collection
of exotic animal milk.
- OK, let's get to it.
- [Narrator] Meet Doctor Michael Power.
Can I call you Mike?
- Sure.
- [Narrator] OK, Mike.
What do you do here?
- I'm the curator of the
Exotic Animal Milk Repository
at the Smithsonian's National Zoo.
It's the largest, by a species count,
number of samples of
milk in the entire world.
(light music)
We have samples that have been collected
from all over the world
that we keep in frozen storage.
- [Narrator] Animals like?
- Armadillos, bats, giraffe,
giant ant eater,
Asian elephant,
African lion,
cheetahs,
tigers, sea lions,
and zebra.
- [Narrator] I hate to ask,
but how do you get the milk?
- [Michael] Well I'll Batang show you.
Batang is a critically
endangered Bornean orangutan.
So this is the classic collaboration
between a scientist and
the animal care staff.
Their incredible work
and effort to be able
to training the animals to be
able to accept this procedure
to where they voluntarily donate samples.
- [Narrator] So now that we know the how,
we have to ask,
why?
- The exotic mammal milk
repository serves two
critical purposes.
One is basic science and
simply trying to understand,
in a sense, the origin of milk,
and the other is a very
practical, pragmatic purpose
in the fact that we have to
occasionally hand-rear animals,
and therefore we have to come up
with a milk replacer formula.
- [Narrator] OK,
so when a baby can't
be fed by their mother,
you guys help come up with the formula
that's as close to the
mother's milk as possible.
- Have you heard about baby Fiona
at the Cincinnati Zoo?
(TV static)
- Is the baby hippo,
who has stolen the hearts of
people all over the country.
- Baby Fiona was born six weeks premature.
She's a Nile hippo,
and no other baby hippo
hand been hand-raised
in North America.
And so we needed to put
together a milk formula
to be able to feed her to have her grow.
So we worked together
with the Exotic Animal Milk
Repository at the National Zoo
to come up with a formula
to feed baby Fiona.
- [Narrator] So how's Fiona doing now?
- [Barbara] Milk is almost
removed from her diet.
We are very happy that baby
Fiona is happy and healthy,
and growing very well.
- [Narrator] Awesome.
Back to Mike.
- So, what's next?
- The milk repository has
samples from over 180 species
of mammals and that
sounds pretty impressive,
until you realize that there's anywhere
from 5,000 to 6,000 species of mammals.
So we have only sampled
maybe 3% of the mammals.
It's still only a tiny tip of the iceberg
compared to what we could be learning.
(light music)